kontakt meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
bei der bundespressekonferenz
wir begrüßen als gäste bei uns heute die
bundesministerin der verteidigung für
annegret kramp karrenbauer und dem
generalinspekteur der bundeswehr general
eberhard zorn und mit auf dem podium ist
er leiter des informations und
pressesprecher des
bundesverteidigungsminister ministeriums
christian thiel herzlich willkommen in
vielen dank für ihren besuch in der
bundespressekonferenz weil auch diese
pressekonferenz auf großes interesse
stößt auch in einer besonderen zeit
stattfindet und von verschiedenen
fernsehsendern live übertragen wird
gruß auch an die zuschauer daheim und
eine erklärung vor ab weil wir gemerkt
haben dass erklärungsbedürftig ist da
das ist eine veranstaltung der
bundespressekonferenz die
bundespressekonferenz ist eine
unabhängige organisation der
journalistinnen und journalisten in
berlin
die über das parlament über die
bundesregierung über politik in berlin
berichten der gewährleisten dass hier
alle fragen von journalisten von den
mitgliedern der bundespressekonferenz
und von ausländischen kollegen im verein
der auslandspresse gestellt werden
können
wir freuen uns dass gäste dass minister
die frau ministerin kramp-karrenbauer
die sprecherinnen und sprecher der
bundesregierung hier auch in diesen
zeiten regelmäßig bei uns zu gast sind
und in besonderen zeiten werden diese
pressekonferenzen hier live übertragen
neu ab heute ist dass wir auch eine
gebärdendolmetscherin bei uns haben
organisiert von den kollegen vom
fernsehsender phoenix vielen dank auch
dafür herzlich willkommen rallye car
wash vielen dank dass sie diese
pressekonferenz auch in gebärdensprache
übersetzen
die bundesministerin beginnt dann
general zorn und dann ist der raum für
ihre fragen ihr aus dem raum und von
außen über dieses bei unserer
kommunikationstool bittet minister sehr
geehrter herr dr
verehrte damen und herren die bekämpfung
des corona virus fordert und derzeit
alle die bundeskanzlerin hat gestern
darauf hingewiesen dass wir noch nie
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg so gefordert
waren wie das zurzeit der fall ist und
das gilt natürlich auch für die
bundeswehr
uns allen muss bewusst sein dass dieser
kampf gegen das virus ein marathon ist
und dass es am ende vor allen dingen
darauf ankommen wird dass wir über lange
strecken auch fähigkeiten vorhalten
fähigkeiten auch zur verfügung stellen
können und das wird insbesondere die
aufgabe der bundeswehr sein
deswegen sind wir im moment noch nicht
so gefordert wie andere zivilen stellen
aber wir bereiten uns darauf vor dass
dann wenn die durchhaltefähigkeit auch
der zivilen kräfte an eine grenze kommt
die bundeswehr insbesondere mit ihren
assets zur verfügung steht dass es der
grund weshalb wir in den letzten wochen
oder die letzten wochen und tage
insbesondere auch genutzt haben um
hinter den kulissen uns auf die
zunehmenden ausgabe aufgaben und
anforderungen uns vorzubereiten und
insbesondere auch in einer sehr
pragmatischen art und weise vor allen
dingen bei der beschaffung von
schutzkleidung von schutzausrüstung und
medizinischen geräten medizinischen und
medizin zu helfen
die bundeswehr das gilt wie für alle
menschen in diesem land sind natürlich
betroffen als mensch als
familienmitglied bürgern bürgerinnen
aber auch an der arbeitsstelle im
sozialleben müssen wir alle zur zeit
einschränkungen und veränderungen
hinnehmen und uns alle zu einem
verantwortungsbewussten handeln
disziplinieren
die bundeswehr unterstützt seit wochen
ich hab das eben gesagt mit ganzer kraft
um die ausreifung der pandemie in
deutschland zu verlangsamen
diese aufgabe wird uns noch lange
fordern und es gilt den einzelnen
kräften und mit den einzelnen kräften
auch denen der bundeswehr
vorausschauend umzugehen ich möchte
daher heute gerne die gelegenheit
ergreifen sie über die maßnahmen zu
informieren wie die bundeswehr in der
derzeitigen lage ihren kernauftrag
weiter sicherstellen wird und
gleichzeitig ihre eigenen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
schützen möchte wie wir zweitens in der
krise helfen können und helfen werden
und drittens wie wir die unsere
anstrengungen unternehmen um zusätzliche
reservekräfte zu organisieren
denn gerade in diesen schwierigen zeiten
können sich die bürgerinnen und bürger
in deutschland auf ihre bundeswehr
verlassen deswegen sitzt heute hier in
meiner seite auch der generalinspekteur
der höchste militärische vorgesetzte der
bundeswehr und wir beide stehen ihnen
natürlich auch sehr gerne rede und
antwort für ihre fragen
erster punkt ist das sicherstellen des
kernauftrags und der schutz der eigenen
männer und frauen die dauer
einsatzaufgaben und die laufenden
mandate müssen sichergestellt werden das
ist die höchste priorität
das bedeutet und betrifft zum beispiel
die fähigkeit dazu dass wir deutsche
staatsbürger aus dem ausland zurückholen
meine im moment nicht den großen
transport den das auswärtige amt
organisiert hat sondern ich meine den
rücktransport insbesondere in
schwierigen situationen aus krisenhaften
situationen
dazu haben wir die kapazitäten
vorzuhalten und diese sind auch
einsatzfähig zur wahrung der lufthoheit
und zur sicherung des luftraums halten
wir unsere alarmrotte permanent in
bereitschaft wir werden im übrigen auch
dass er politik im baltikum als nordost
lange des luftraums der nato weiter mit
absichern wir werden dort ende 2020 die
führung übernehmen
wir haben bündnisverpflichtungen und
mandatierte einsätze und das bleibt für
uns die militärische messlatte wir
prüfen derzeit natürlich wie wir die
notwendigen quarantänemaßnahmen in die
einsatz verpflichtungen so integrieren
dass kontingentwechsel wie geplant
stattfinden können
wir haben zurzeit je nach aufnahmeland
im moment bedingungen dass kräfte die
eingewechselt werden eine zweiwöchige
quarantäne durchlaufen müssen und wir
wollen natürlich insbesondere die männer
und frauen die jetzt schon seit monaten
im einsatz sind und auf die ja auch ihre
eigenen familien warten auch in einer
verlässlichen art und weise wieder
zurückholen deswegen muss das
entsprechend neu organisiert werden
wir legen im moment einen großen wert
auf den eigenschutz der angehörigen der
bundeswehr und das dient einzig und
allein dem zweck dass wir das größte das
wir haben und das sind eben unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten dass wir die so
weit schützen dass wir unseren beitrag
dazu leisten dass sich die pandemie
im moment nicht schneller und weiter
verbreitet aber dass wir vor allen
dingen dieser männer und frauen auch zur
verfügung haben wenn es darauf ankommt
dass wir mit unseren kräften einspringen
müssen weil andere kräfte eben an das
ende ihrer leistungsfähigkeit gekommen
sind
wir haben wenn sie so wollen vier eigene
gesundheitsämter das nennt sich im
behördendeutsch die überwachung stellen
für öffentlich-rechtliche aufgaben die
in enger zusammenarbeit mit den zivilen
gesundheitsämtern die gesetze des
infektionsschutzgesetzes natürlich auch
für die bundeswehr umsetzen
unser sanitätsdienst hat weitreichende
maßnahmen eingeleitet für die eigenen
kräfte um mit der situation umzugehen
dazu gehört die verfügbarkeit von 1200
isolations betreuungsmöglichkeiten in
den kasernen der sanitäts
versorgungszentren
dazu gehört die erhöhung der isolations
möglichkeiten in den 5
bundeswehrkrankenhäusern durch die
reduktion der planbaren eingriffen
dadurch dass wir material aus unseren
einsatz lazaretten beatmungsgeräte auch
dorthin verbringen
ich will an dieser stelle ausdrücklich
darauf hinweisen 60 bis 70 prozent der
patienten in den
bundeswehrkrankenhäusern sind zivilisten
also das heißt wir bieten mit dem
bundeswehr krankenhäusern sind auch ein
teil der zivilen gesundheitsvorsorge
wir setzen die richtlinien des rk ii in
unseren hausarzt praxen um die pflegen
eine sehr intensive arbeitsbeziehung zum
rk ii wir tauschen uns kontinuierlich
mit den einsatz kontingenten aus und
untersuchen vorverlegung von soldatinnen
und soldaten eben dieselben auf eine
infektion mit krone dass es deshalb
wichtig damit wir in länder die über
kein funktionierendes gesundheitssystem
verfügen nicht noch zusätzlich den virus
einschleppen wenn sie sich vorstellen
unsere kräfte in mali bei der situation
in mali dass wir sozusagen noch vor oder
infizierte
dort hinein bringen würden das ist
unverantwortlich deswegen muss das sehr
gut auch untersucht werden
zweitens wir helfen in der krise wir
haben neben den säulen oder kontingenten
wenn sie so wollen
für die einsätze für die einsatz
gleichung verpflichtungen für landes-
und bündnisverteidigung für den
grundbetrieb auch ein einsatzkontingent
schutz vor corona entwickelt und wir
wollen mit diesem einsatzkontingent eben
auch im rahmen der amtshilfe und im
rahmen der rechtlichen möglichkeiten
unseren beitrag leisten um die situation
in deutschland aufrecht zu erhalten
der sanitätsdienst der bundeswehr ist
hier besonders gefordert er ist im
normalbetrieb in das system der zivilen
gesundheitsvorsorge eingebunden
eigentlich ist er gedacht um mögliche
schwerverletzte aus einsätzen in
deutschland versorgen zu können
wir werden aber bei der verlangsamung
der pandemie ausbreitung in deutschland
alles tun was in unserer macht steht
trotzdem das möchte ich an dieser stelle
ganz deutlich sagen und auch warnen vor
überzogenen erwartungen
wie es in dem deutschen gesundheitswesen
ein juniorpartner
wir haben zurzeit im rahmen der
bundeswehr circa 3000 ärzte und
ärztinnen der verschiedenen
fachrichtungen die im gesamt konzert des
deutschen gesundheitswesens eine
hervorragend qualifizierte aber eben
auch eine relativ kleine gruppe
darstellen
darüber hinaus können und so weit uns
das möglich ist beantworten wir auch
positiv die anfragen der lokalen und
regionalen behörden auf amtshilfe um
etwa feldbett nur der lagerkapazitäten
zur verfügung zu stellen oder
beschaffungen von medizinischen
ausrüstung vorzunehmen
zurzeit laufen schon im rahmen der
amtshilfe entsprechende maßnahmen
wir haben aktuell rund 50 anfragen das
sind hilfe leistungsanträge und
voranfragen von denen bisher 13
unterstützt werden konnte in der
aktuellen situation sind schnelle
entscheidungen wichtig damit den vor ort
eingesetzten kräften und der bevölkerung
zeitnah geholfen werden kann
die wesentlichen amtshilfe leistungen
konzentrieren sich zurzeit vor allen
dingen auf das thema beschaffung von
medizinischem material durch unser
beschaffungsamt des bbw die ganzen
großen maschen die gestern ja
dankenswerterweise deshalb der
gesundheitsminister auch gesagt jetzt
immer stärker auch nicht nur geordnet
sind sondern auch hier in deutschland
ankommen und jetzt nach und nach in die
verteilung auch an die bundesländer
gehen sind im wesentlichen vom bein bw
unserem beschaffungsamt besorgt worden
und ich gestatten sie mir dass ich will
dass an dieser stelle mal sagen weil ja
oft gerade das beschaffungswesen der
bundeswehr kritisiert wird aber die
kolleginnen und kollegen in beim bw
haben jetzt seit wochen sonder gruppen
gebildet sind seit wochen fast rund um
die uhr dabei rund um den globus alles
zu besorgen was man an schutzmasken an
ausstattung an atmungs geräten bekommen
kann und leisten eine ganz hervorragende
arbeit wofür ich mich ganz herzlich
bedanken will
wir helfen aber eben auch im kleinen
zurzeit und aktuell unterstützen zb 50
soldatinnen und soldaten bei der
versorgung von lkw fahrern die vor der
grenze nach polen in sachsen in einem 60
kilometer langen stau stecken
die entscheidung für einen weiteren
anfragen stehen noch aus sie richten
sich vor allen dingen immer nach der
frage was wir an ressourcen zur
verfügung haben
aber wir werden so lange unterstützen
wie wir gebraucht werden und so lange
wie wir die geeigneten männer und frauen
und die ausrüstung und das material
der dritte große punkt für uns ist das
bereitstellen zusätzlicher reservekräfte
wenn wir vom verband der reservisten
ausgehen in dem rund 120.000
reservistinnen und reservisten
organisiert sind dann leiten wir davon
ab dass wir circa eine summe von 75.000
dass er ist ihre reservisten haben von
denen wir sozusagen die namen haben die
erreichbarkeiten haben die für uns auch
proaktiv sofort ansprechbar sind
die bundeswehr verfügt mit dieser großen
anzahl über einen großen pool an
spezialisten
wir haben deswegen ja am wochenende
schon mit der sanität entsprechende
aufrufe gestartet bis stand heute sind
haben sich auf diesen aufruf der sanität
2336 reservistinnen und reservisten
gemeldet von denen wir rund 935 aufgrund
von vor dienstzeit und erfahrung im
sanitätsdienst der bundeswehr sehr
zeitnah zur verfügung haben und die wir
auch entsprechend einsetzen können
jetzt geht es darum dass wir die auch in
den anderen truppenteilen reservistinnen
und reservisten aufrufen wir wollen dies
in zweierlei hinsicht machen zum einen
durch sehr gezielte aufrufe dort wo wir
feststellen dass wir über den bestand
der aktiven truppe hinaus bedarf haben
dort werden wir uns gezielt an dieser
reservisten wenden
aber auch durch einen allgemeinen aufruf
wir haben rund 28.000 sogenannte
beorderte reservistinnen und reservisten
das sind diejenigen die schon für
gewisse unter bestimmte stellen auch
vorgesehen sind
die können sich bei diesen stellen
melden
alle die ungeordnet sind haben wir eine
eigene stelle im personalamt der
bundeswehr in köln
unter dem titel reserve hilft dort kann
man sich hinwenden und dort findet dann
auch in zusammenarbeit auch mit den
regionalen verantwortlichen die
zuordnung auch in die regionalen
zuständigkeiten stadt die führungs und
einsatzfähigkeit der bundeswehr behält
bei der verteilung unserer kräfte die
höchste priorität das gilt vor allen
dingen für die unterstützung von
soldatinnen und soldaten in den derzeit
laufenden mandatierten auslandseinsätzen
die bundeswehr stellt darüber hinaus
aber alle verfügbaren kräfte für die
gemeinschaftlichen aufgaben der pandemie
eindämmung bereit wenn länder und
gemeinden die wirtschaft die polizeien
das technische hilfswerk und alle
weiteren institutionen an die grenzen
kommen dann werden wir
selbstverständlich auch helfen gerade
aktuell versuchen wir logistische
kapazitäten etwa im bereich der
gütertransporte für weitere amtshilfe
freizumachen
und ich will mit blick auch auf das
thema sicherheit und ordnung nur ganz
deutlich sagen das ist natürlich die
ganz vorrangige aufgabe der
sicherheitsbehörden der zivilen
sicherheitsbehörden der polizeien des
bundes und der länder und die
möglichkeit der bundeswehr dort zu
unterstützen kann immer nur erfolgen bei
einer bei einer entsprechenden antrag
stellung auch durch die entsprechenden
behörden und auch nur unter engen
voraussetzungen
aber wenn es zum beispiel darum gehen
sollte das kritische infrastruktur wie
elektrizitätswerke die wasserwerke die
zurzeit etwa durch private wachdienste
auch geschützt werden dass dort der
schutz zb ausfällt dann wäre das etwas
wo die bundeswehr auch mit einzusetzen
ist auch darüber befinden wir uns
einem engen austausch mit den
bundesländern ich habe in dieser woche
noch einmal persönlich mit allen
regierungschefin und chefs der länder
telefoniert um mir ein eigenes bild über
die lage vor ort zu machen auch darüber
zu reden was vor ort von der bundeswehr
gewünscht und gebraucht wird und in der
tat gibt es bundesländer die zb die
bundeswehr auch anfragen in der
unterstützung ihrer eigenen
polizeilichen aufgaben also dass es
nicht aus der luft gegriffen sondern das
sind anfragen die schon auf dem tisch
liegen
in dieser krise gilt es sicherlich für
jeden einzelnen bundeswehrangehörigen
dass er sich an das hält was wir alle
miteinander vereinbart haben nämlich
nach außen abstand zu wahren
aber in der ersten zuwendung auch bereit
zu stehen und zu zeigen dass die
bundeswehr eine unentbehrliche und
verlässliche stütze unsere gemein
unseres gemeinwesens ist wir haben uns
ja selbst dem wahlspruch gegeben wir
dienen deutschland und das gilt
sicherlich und ganz besonders in einer
zeit wie wir sie gerade erleben dass in
vielen dank herr general zorn
ja ich würde gerne nochmal ergänzen
wollen dass die bundeswehr insgesamt
sich jetzt seit der vergangenen woche so
eingestellt hat dass wir vom ministerium
aus bis in die unteren führungsebenen in
allen bereichen lagezentren eingerichtet
haben das heißt wir sind ansprechbar und
führungsfähigkeit der spitze bis in die
tiefen ebenen unseres gesamtsystems alle
unsere soldaten die wir aktuell nicht
dringend für die aktuellen aufgaben
brauchen haben wir wie in einem
schichtbetrieb muss man sich das
vorstellen
zunächst mal nach hause geschickt das
heißt wir haben überall reduziert sind
teilweise nur zu 50 prozent manchmal
auch in drittel schichten dann
entsprechend in unseren jeweiligen
funktionen eingesetzt das führt dazu
dass wir eine höhere durchhaltefähigkeit
für uns generieren und vor allem dem
schutz unserer eigenen soldaten auch
entsprechend rechnung tragen mit blick
auf die auslandseinsätze die ministerin
hat das angesprochen ist die situation
in allen einsatzgebieten unterschiedlich
wir respektieren dort natürlich überall
die jeweiligen forderungen
mit blick auf quarantäne und
gesundheitsschutz der jeweilige einsatz
länder
wir selber haben für unsere soldaten in
allen fällen in der regel davor und
danach eine entsprechende quarantänezeit
eingeplant in der regel von 14 tagen
das bedeutet dass unsere soldaten also
hier auch wieder eine erhebliche
zusätzliche belastung erfahren
zu den einsatz dauert insgesamt das wird
auch auswirkungen haben auf die
durchführung der kontingentwechsel das
letzter zeit sehr eng im augenblick aus
geplant mit blick auf die möglichkeiten
hier zu hause ist der sanitätsdienst
natürlich besonders gefordert auch nach
innen hinein
wir haben uns eingestellt jetzt in den
kategorien die die ministerin
angesprochen hat also in der säule
kontingent amtshilfe auf verschiedene
optionen die wir auch schon durchdacht
haben was eine ist der bereich der
unterbringung infrastruktur also wie
können man kann man unterstützen im
bereich der kaserne
das thema ist transport wir sind ja
flächendeckend abgedeckt mit unseren
logistik und versorgungs bataillonen die
hier unterstützen könnten so die
amtshilfe anträge entsprechend vorliegen
und wir können unterstützen den bereich
von lagerung und von entsprechenden
umschlag kapazitäten das heißt hier sind
wir dabei die entsprechenden fähigkeiten
aufzustellen
da wird die federführung liegen bei der
streitkräftebasis also den territorialen
kommandobereich der für diese dinge
zuständig sagen würde das vielleicht
noch als ergänzung dazu in vielen dank
vielen dank dann kommen wir zu ihren
fragen und fangen bei ihnen an
und dann arbeiten wir uns hier durch die
ersten fragen sind auch extern schon
aufgenommen bitte
[Musik]
also marathon wo stehen wir im moment
ich glaube die frage wie lange dieser
marathon wird hängt sehr von uns selbst
ab
je stärker wir uns jetzt an die ja sehr
massiven einschränkungen halten jeder
einzelne von uns
oder um es ganz deutlich zu sagen jede
corona party die nicht stattfindet jeder
sturm eines baumarktes der jetzt zur
zeit unterlassen wird jeder abstand der
beim einkaufen eingehalten wird dient
dazu dass die verbreitung des virus
verlangsamt wird und hilft dabei
möglicherweise andere maßnahmen eben
verhindern zu können
wer keine dauerhafte ausgangssperre will
mit all seinen belastungen der muss
jetzt selbst höchste disziplin waren
insofern da wir eigentlich erst am
mittwoch flächendeckend diese maßnahmen
denn dann umgesetzt haben liegt es jetzt
in der hand jedes einzelnen seinen
beitrag dazu zu leisten dass die
bekämpfung des des corona virus und dass
dieser marathon etwas kürzer wird aber
wir stellen uns als bundeswehr eben auch
auf ein worst case ein dass es länger
dauern könnte das zivile strukturen
wirklich massiv unter druck kommen und
wir haben eben eine große ressource
personal und wir sind dann diejenigen
die insbesondere gefordert sind um auch
über eine längere wegstrecke die
durchhaltefähigkeit zu gewährleisten und
darauf konzentrieren wir uns das
bedeutet aber eben auch dass wir im
moment noch nicht alle amtshilfe anträge
dann auch sofort und im großen umfang
erfüllen können solange es dafür zb auch
noch zivile möglichkeiten gibt sondern
dass wir eben auch assets noch ein stück
weit auch für eine längere wegstrecke
behalten müssten
ob jetzt ein allgemeines dienst ja die
situation die wir haben wirklich
verbessern würde es eine relativ
theoretische diskussion denn wir haben
das dienst ja nicht aber was wir haben
und da stelle ich fest nicht nur mit
blick auf die eigene reserve sondern
auch wenn ich in die gesellschaft hinein
blicke und auch wenn ich in das netz
hinein blicken dass wir jede menge
freiwillige haben
es gibt eben nicht nur diejenigen die
korona party feiern sondern es gibt
diejenigen die einkaufs helden sind die
nachbarschafts betreuung machen die
unterstützen die sich melden auch bei
uns und die große kunst wird jetzt auch
sein und das versuchen wir in der
bundeswehr eben auch so gut zu
organisieren wie es geht dass wir die so
organisieren dass vor allen dingen dann
wenn die situation jetzt dringender wird
dass wir dann die die struktur so haben
dass rechtzeitig jeder der freiwillig
helfen will auch dorthin kommt wo die
hilfe gebraucht wird das ist glaube ich
die aufgabe die wir jetzt noch hinter
den kulissen sehr stark nutzen sollten
was eine ausgangssperre konkret für die
organisation der soldatinnen und
soldaten bedeuten würde
das müssen wir besprechen insbesondere
dort wo soldatinnen soldaten natürlich
im zuge der amtshilfe gebraucht werden
müssen sie natürlich auch freie
bewegungsfreiheit haben was das
möglicherweise für die unterbringung
bedeutet würde ich gerne dem gegen das
wort noch mal geben
ja wir haben die situation dass wir
soldaten haben die in kasernen wohnen
also die dort ihren wohnsitz haben so
die nicht gebraucht werden für eine
amtshilfe leistung oder eine dienstliche
verrichtung sind sie natürlich genauso
an ausgangs beschränkungen gehalten die
durch die regierung verordnet werden
wenn es denn so kommt wie alle anderen
mitbürger auch die soldaten die wir
jetzt nach hause geschickt haben die
also nicht in ihren dienststellen dienst
tun
im augenblick unterliegen dort auch den
gleichen rahmenrichtlinien die die
bundesregierung heraus gegeben hat wie
wir alle
das heißt also wenn es zu irgendwelchen
auflagen kommt sind die auch zu
respektieren ausnahme sie werden im
dienst gebraucht wir haben dazu auch ein
entsprechendes verfahren etabliert also
der truppen ausweis des soldaten und ein
dazugehöriges begleitschreiben weisen
aus dass der soldat zu dienst
verrichtung verpflichtet ist und damit
ist natürlich dann auch in der lage sich
entsprechend zu bewegen das einsatzjahr
hülle zu setzen
ja da gehe ich erst mal von aus denn
sonst können sie ihren dienst nicht
verrichten also das heißt der dir zu
hause wohnt also so wie ich
beispielsweise ich wohl nicht in der
kaserne
ich muss natürlich irgendwie zu meinen
dies dort hinkommen um meine aufgabe
nachzukommen also dafür wird es mit
sicherheit ausnahmeregelung geben
ähnliches denke ich wird es auch geben
wenn es denn kommt für polizei
hilfsdienste und andere das heißt also
die unterstützungsleistung für die stadt
die handlungsfähigkeit muss im wald ihr
gestellt werden da gehe ich von außen
mit der nächsten frage 2 1 nach vorne da
noch gering also wir haben zurzeit stand
gestern abend rund 50 amtshilfe anträge
wovon ein großer teil eben auch am tv
anderer bundesministerien sind was zum
beispiel das thema beschaffung anbelangt
der generalinspekteur hat es ja eben
gesagt wir haben unsere gesamte kette
sozusagen aktiviert das heißt auch alle
unsere ansprechpartner auf den
kommunalen ebenen in den landeskommandos
sind in der struktur aufgebaut
zurzeit geht sind sozusagen die anträge
die wir haben vor allen dingen das thema
beschaffung das geht über die
bundesebene
es sind anträge auf
hilfe bei schutzausstattung da muss ich
noch mal ganz deutlich sagen die
schutzausstattung die wir geschafft
haben über die verfügen wir nicht als
verteidigungsministerium oder als
bundeswehr sondern dass es die über die
das bundesgesundheitsministerium verfügt
und die an die länder auch entsprechend
verausgabt wird ansonsten haben wir eben
schutzausstattung auch für unsere
eigenen truppen der zweite große
teilbereich ist eben die frage der hilfe
bei zb mit personal bei fieber
ambulanzen das haben wir jetzt in
koblenz unterstützen wir dort des
aufbaus von feldbetten auch der frage
bei testung mit laborkapazitäten und das
was wir selbst an laborkapazitäten zur
verfügung haben und was wir nicht für
den eigenen bedarf sozusagen aufbrauchen
stellen wir auch zur verfügung aber das
ist vergleichsweise gering
wir haben jetzt zunehmend auch anfragen
zum thema logistik also insbesondere von
den bundesländern die zb durch die sehr
schwierigen grenzkontrollen zur
polnischen grenze betroffen sind
dort planen wir im moment eben ja auch
auszuhelfen
aber ich wäre das an der stelle noch
einmal betonen es gibt natürlich auch
viele lösungen die zivil im grunde
genommen zuerst einmal und besser zu
organisieren sind als militärische ich
will das an einem beispiel deutlich
machen wenn es zum beispiel um die frage
geht wo kann man zusätzliche
infrastruktur aufbauen etwa um patienten
auch zu isolieren
dann kommen natürlich zählte zb in frage
aber nicht erreichen im minuten-takt die
auch die hinweise und angebote vom hotel
zum beispiel in deutschland die sagen
durch die entscheidung wir haben
kapazitäten leer wir haben
zimmer frei bei uns kann man das
aufbauen und das natürlich für die
menschen die sehr viel bessere
unterbringung als in einem feldlager
also deswegen muss man auch mit sinn und
verstand schauen was kann man machen und
wenn sie fragen wann sind wir
handlungsfähig wir sind handlungsfähig
wir haben in den letzten tagen und
wochen wirklich aufgebaut haben uns alle
aktiviert und natürlich geht das immer
einen schritt weiter voran so wie es die
lage erfordert aber das was von uns
gebraucht wird können und werden wir
liefern
zusatzfrage bitte ja wir haben eine zb
eine konkrete anfrage aus thüringen
da geht es auch um den
einsatz unserer kräfte in einer aufnahme
unterkunft die im moment mit allen ein
mit allen bewohnerinnen und bewohnern
unter quarantäne steht und wo die
zivilen kräfte also die privaten
sicherungs dienste eben auch im moment
nicht so verfügbar sind
es geht um die frage ob wir zum beispiel
dort wo die bilanzen oder die test
stellen eingerichtet sind und wo wir zum
teil das in räumlichkeiten machen die
von privaten zur verfügung gestellt
werden zum beispiel über die kv ob wir
das in eine zum beispiel anderer
umgebung innerhalb einer kaserne zb
verlagern können um dort auch die
zugänge auch besser ordnen zu können
weil wir dort einen sehr großen ansturm
von menschen haben die auch ohne
überweisung getestet werden wollen also
das sind ganz konkrete anfragen die wir
zurzeit auf dem tisch haben sie
vielleicht an der stelle fragen von
außen rein und bündel das mal fragen die
von tobias schulze von der taz von kai
clement von der ard von daniela vatis
vom rnd aufgeworfen werden sich auf das
thema amtshilfe konkret auf polizeiliche
aufgaben und sie ihnen handelt es sich
dabei um polizeiliche aufgaben auf
welcher grundrechts grundlage für die
bundeswehr im bereich polizeilicher
aufgaben tätig und generell die frage ob
und gegebenenfalls mit welcher
bewaffnung die bundeswehr dabei
auftreten könnte und würde und ob
dadurch auslandseinsätze beeinträchtigt
werden also das was wir zurzeit leisten
und was wir auch in einem großen umfang
leisten können ist eine amtshilfe nach
artikel 35 absatz 1 grundgesetz
dies gibt uns schon einen großen
spielraum dessen was wir tun können
für den einsatz daneben gibt es noch den
artikel 35 ab zu zwei grundgesetz das
ist die klassische katastrophenhilfe die
an rechtliche enge rechtliche auflagen
gebunden ist und die deshalb an enge
auflagen gebunden ist weil mit ihr eben
auch die wahrnehmung hoheitlicher
aufgaben verbunden sein könnte
das worum es im moment geht wird sich
alles im bereich der amtshilfe ab und
ich habe ja eben sehr sehr deutlich
gesagt insbesondere die frage ob
bundeswehr auch im bereich polizeien mit
eingebunden wird ist eine die rechtlich
sehr enge voraussetzungen hat und die
deswegen auch sehr genau auch rechtlich
beurteilt werden muss
aber um diese fragen geht es auch nicht
geht es zurzeit auch nicht und wir sind
wenn ich mir die situation in den
polizeien der länder anschaue auch das
was mir die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten gesagt haben auch
noch ein ganz gutes stück davon entfernt
dass die bundeswehr dort irgendwie
unterstützen misst und ich will dass an
der stelle wenn sie mir es gestatten
auch sagen ich weiß wir leiden im moment
ja alle darunter dass sehr viele
falschinformationen fake news gerüchte
insbesondere auch durch das netz
geistern und auch dort gibt es gerüchte
über allgemeine ausgangssperren die die
bundeswehr sozusagen
auch entsprechend kontrollieren soll
auf dessen einhaltung sie achten soll
das ist alles nicht der fall das ist
auch nicht das was wir tun wollen was
wir tun können sondern ich habe eben
gesagt wenn es zum beispiel darum geht
ganz konkret ein wasserwerk das zurzeit
von einem privaten wachdienst bewacht
wird und wo der private wachdienst
aufgrund von infektionen einfach
ausfällt dann ist zum beispiel die frage
kann die bundeswehr das übernehmen wir
haben die frage im übrigen bei unseren
eigenen person in unsere eigene kasernen
werden zurzeit im normalbetrieb außen
von privaten wachdiensten geschützt wenn
die natürlich ausfallen ist die erste
aufgabe der bundeswehr ihre eigenen
liegenschaften zu sichern
also insofern sind wir damit auch gut
beschäftigt und deswegen ist das was
zurzeit auch an anfragen auf dem tisch
liegt alles das was sich im rahmen der
amtshilfe nach artikel 35 absatz 1
abspiele frage nach bewaffnung
vielleicht kann man da noch was
antworten das wird jetzt in mehreren
zusammenhängen gestellt es kommen auch
nachfragen etwa von christopher ziedler
von der stuttgarter zeitung
ob das denkbar wäre dass
bundeswehrsoldaten im rahmen dieser
deutschen städte im rahmen der amtshilfe
in deutschen städten patroullieren dass
ich sie im augenblick dazu weder anträge
die dieses von uns fordern
noch sehe ich jetzt im augenblick das
bild häufig verbinden ja die das
internet oder wo auch immer nachfragen
damit das bild was sie aus frankreich
oder belgien möglicherweise kennen
dieses bild sehe ich in deutschland so
nicht
ich sehe auch hier keine schweren waffen
also wenn sie unlängst im internet
verfolgt haben dass wir hier den
aufmarsch mit panzer artillerie proben
da kann ich sie beruhigen das sind
schlichtweg alles die transporte die
jetzt im nachgang zur beendeten übung
defender europe 2020 stattfinden
das heißt dass in reguläre
truppentransporte die wir jetzt weiter
unterstützen
also es ist nicht davon auszugehen dass
wir jetzt hier in irgendeiner form einen
aufmarsch machen das gleiche gilt wenn
sie es überhaupt über die bewaffnung
fragen
können sie sich das beispiel nehmen an
unseren eigenen bewachung in unserer
kasernen wir überwachen die mit pistole
und mit gewehr das sind die hand waffen
die wir dort dort nutzen und zwar unter
der engen auflage der entsprechenden
gesetzlichen rahmenbedingungen das ist
das gesetz zur ausübung des
unmittelbaren zwangs was dazu trägt das
heißt wir haben also hier eine ganz
klare limitierung durch unsere
rechtsstaatlichen vorgaben und an dieses
jahr unverändert gehalten also es
braucht sich keiner sorgen machen dass
die bundeswehr kroner partys auflöst
oder ausgangs beschränkungen überwacht
dann erinc und verein
zahlen denn damit geschafft wird das duo
findet alles erreicht wenn keine
gedanken
das verteidigungsressort sind
dazu zählen und dritte frage von 7 oder
bei der selbst die sie ist eigentlich
hält ist eigentlich geklärt ist dass die
arbeitgeber den falschen müssen also wir
haben die beschaffung im regel im rahmen
des amtshilfeersuchens führt des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums zusammen
vorgenommen mit anderen
beschaffungsstellen des bundes etwa das
holz oder des bundesinnenministeriums
aber wir in der federführung stand heute
haben wir in einer größenordnung von
rund 241 millionen euro material
geschafft das sind schutzanzüge das sind
masken von der einfachen op maske bis
zur über die fdp 2 und die fdp 3 das
sind entsprechendes medizinisches
material das sind medikamente also
beatmungsgeräte also alles das was ich
sage
der markt hergibt und der das
beschaffungs soll ist noch mal am 17
märz erhöht worden
für die massen beschaffungen zb
insbesondere von masken und von anderen
persönliche schutzausstattung sind die
verträge alle abgeschlossen worden wie
der zulauf der marschen erfolgt gerade
zur zeit beziehungsweise soll dann
anfang april auf folgen
es wird so sein dass das
gesundheitsministerium von uns sozusagen
das was beschafft wird entsprechend
erhält und das gesundheitsministerium
dann auch nach einem entsprechenden plan
und nach absprachen mit den
bundesländern das material dann auch die
bundesländer weiter verteilt die
beschaffung ist eine laufende maßnahme
das heißt wir schauen natürlich im
moment auch über unsere beschaffungs
ämter über den gesamten markt auf der
ganzen welt und wo immer wir
wirklich auch material bekommen können
versuchen wir das natürlich auch zu
ordern und wichtig ist natürlich dass
wir auch bei diesen beschaffungen die
qualitätskriterien und die medizinischen
standards wie man zb für eine ft2 masco
der fdp drei maß gebraucht dass die
erfüllt sind und sie können sich auch
vorstellen dass im zuge der krise nicht
alle unternehmen die angebote abgeben
auch wirklich seriöse unternehmen sind
also auch das muss geprüft werden und
das haben unsere mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter wirklich unter hohem
zeitdruck mit einer hohen qualität auch
entsprechend getan
der jetzt habe ich vor lauter erklärung
die zweite frage ja also man muss
nochmal unterscheiden das eine sind die
die echten intensivbetten auch mit dem
beatmungs kapazitäten da ist das was wir
in der bundeswehr in den krankenhäusern
bieten natürlich bestandteil der 28.000
die wir haben und es gibt ja die
zielsetzung mit den bundesländern dass
die zahl der krankenhausbetten also das
sind roundabout 500.000 verdoppelt
werden soll und die zahl der
intensivbetten von 28.000 eben auch
verdoppelt werden soll
auf 56.000 das sind die anstrengungen
die wir im moment auch in den eigenen
krankenhäusern unternehmen indem wir
planbare op s verschieben indem wir auch
sozusagen räume frei machen um weitere
intensivbetten dort einzubringen
die isolations betten haben natürlich
noch haben eine andere funktion da geht
es auch darum diejenigen die wir
isolieren müssen und die dass nicht
soziale alleine oder die das nicht
privat tun können weil sie auch eine
gewisse medizinische betreuung brauchen
noch nicht die ganz intensive aber eine
gewisse medizinische betreuung
dazu können wir zu den kapazitäten die
wir dann in der bundeswehr krankenhäuser
haben eben diese 1200 etwa in unserem
kasernen noch mit dazu geben vieles
wollte noch ergänzen
zu der frage reservisten würde ich gern
noch ergänzen
also wir haben nicht den status der
mobilmachung
das heißt es geht immer darum der
reservisten der sich bei uns meldet
meldet sich initiativ er tut das
freiwillig wenn er sich bei uns meldet
dann unter einbeziehung des
einverständnisses seines arbeitgebers
das muss er nicht vorlegen entsprechend
und dann natürlich seine qualifikation
die er im zivilen oder militärischen
bereichen erworben hat damit wir dann
schauen können in welchen bereichen
einsetzbar ist bevor ich weiter gibt
nochmal eine nachfrage von außen zu
einer frage die eben gestellt wurde und
möglicherweise nicht ganz beantwortet
wurde die frage nach auswirkungen auf
die auslandseinsätze
also konkret werden einsätze reduziert
bzw abgebrochen ist die nachfrage von
daniela vaters zb irak auch ganz konkret
generell sagen wir generalinspekteur
wird dazu noch näher ausführen können
wir wollen die einsätze und die
verpflichtung die wir haben auch
aufrechterhalten aber insbesondere dort
wo wir im internationalen missionen
unterwegs sind tun wir das natürlich
immer auch in rücksprache mit den
internationalen partnern und in
rücksicht auf das gastland und wenn du
dann dass das land in dem wir uns
befinden etwa mit blick auf die korona
situation auch entsprechende
ausgangssperren oder anderes verhängt
dann hat das natürlich auswirkungen auf
unseren eigenen einsatz aber zu den
einzelnen einsätzen kann der geht
sicherlich noch mal näher ausführen
ja ich starte mal war das auch schon
angesprochen wurde vorerst mit dem irak
die internationale koalition gegen den
esc hat entschieden im einvernehmen mit
der irakischen regierung das bis zum 11
die ausbildung der irakischen
streitkräfte zunächst unterbrochen wird
das liegt im wesentlichen an der
thematik bedrohung durch den crooner
virus vor diesem hintergrund haben wir
unsere soldaten jetzt zunächst in erbil
zusammengeführt und im moment laufen die
planungen wie wir dort weiter ausdünnen
können das heißt wir wollen das
feldlager weiter natürlich in betrieb
halten damit wir auch ad hoc wieder
dorthin zurück gehen können aber alle
die soldaten die bisher nur in der
ausbildung gebunden war
und jetzt damit keinen auftrag mehr
haben die werden wir spätestens in der
nächsten woche dann nach hause holen
das wäre für den irak in allen anderen
auslandseinsätzen bleiben wir
unverändert präsent wir bilden auch die
nachfolge kontingente entsprechend aus
die ausbildung ist unverändert geplant
wir reduzieren die hier zu hause etwas
um die praxisanteile und um die teile wo
sie sehr viele soldaten zusammen führen
müssen das heißt wir nutzen also die
möglichkeiten auch über internet und
über entsprechend des fern lernmodulen
dann diese soldaten auszubilden und zu
informieren dass wir kombinieren das und
reduzieren auch hier zu hause dann schon
dieses zusammenkommen in großen mengen
alle einsätze kann man im grunde sagen
unterliegen quarantäne auflagen
unterschiedlich je nach land insofern
also eine vorsichtsmaßnahme bevor er zur
soldaten verlegen und alle die die
wieder zurückkommen und da ziehen wir
dann hier zu hause eine entsprechend 14
tägigen quarantäne um auch hier sicher
zu sein für die einen soldaten aber für
unsere gesellschaft dass wir keine
verschleppung von viren nach deutschland
haben dann kommen die nächsten fragen
wieder aus dem saal von frau reimers und
herren carstens
[Musik]
die frage was wir einsetzen wenn wir im
rahmen der amtshilfe solche anfragen
haben die sie eben erwähnt haben
das sind ganz sicherlich auch natürlich
feldjäger aber ob das darüber hinaus
möglicherweise dann auch andere
soldatinnen soldaten sind das müssen
sozusagen immer die entsprechenden
stellen auch mit blick auf die eigenen
kapazitäten und die fähigkeiten die
gefragt werden entsprechend auch
entscheiden was was das thema ausbildung
anbelangt kann der ge sicherlich noch
einmal ergänzen
wir passen dort so an dass wir
diejenigen die jetzt sozusagen auch zur
bundeswehr kommen würden zum ersten
april dass wir das planmäßig durchführen
können aber in einer etwas angepassten
form und natürlich müssen auch wir bei
den ausbildungen entscheiden wir haben
ausbildungsbereiche und anteile
die sind zwingend notwendig da geht es
auch um prüfungen sowie das
etwa an anderen hochschulen oder so auch
der fall ist da müssen wir auch
entsprechende wege finden unter der
einhaltung der der schutzmaßnahmen und
es gibt andere ausbildung muss man sagen
die müssen jetzt erst einmal warten was
die frage der bedrohungslage anbelangt
wir haben ja zeitgleich zur übung
defender 2020 der jetzt beendet worden
ist
auch auf etwa der russischen seite eine
vergleichbare übung gehabt und wir
stellen fest dass die truppen die im
rahmen dieser übung sozusagen an unsere
an die grenze der nato gebracht wurden
sind entgegen früherer gewohnheiten bis
jetzt nicht in die eigenen standorte
wieder zurückgekehrt sind sondern dort
weiter präsent sind also insofern gibt
es für uns auch keinen anlass dass wir
die präsenz etwa in litauen zum beispiel
jetzt reduzieren sollten und was wir
erlebt haben zum beispiel auch bei
defender 2020 waren wirklich glaube das
kann man so sagen auch gezielte
desinformations kampagnen und zum
beispiel dass sich im letzten auch über
entsprechende adressen verbreitet hat
mit den truppen mit den amerikanischen
truppen würde sozusagen das krone virus
ins land hinein geschleppt werden
also diese sei aber angriffe sind für
uns ganz normale realität und die gehen
weiter dann mach ergänzung zur
ausbildung kann ich gerne noch ergänzen
weil sie auch die grundausbildung
ansprache angeht macht das einfach mal
am ersten april fest also jeder der es
zum ersten viertel zu uns kommen soll
wird ab dem moment erster vierter rein
rechtlich gesehen in den status eines
soldaten gebracht er wird aber dann noch
keinen körperlichen dienstantritt in den
einheiten haben sondern wir haben jetzt
im april beispielsweise die letzte
aprilwoche als den dienst antritt
festgelegt das gleiche gilt für mai und
juni dann entsprechend das heißt die
soldaten bekommen von uns dann die
künftigen soldaten einen brief in dem
wir
ihnen mitteilen dass sie zu hause in
ihrer häuslichen quarantäne bleiben
sollen mindestens 14 tage
und jeder der zu uns kommt entsprechend
gesundheitlich dann untersucht und dann
wird gibt es signale symptome was auch
immer auf die wir reagieren müssen
die grundausbildung selber werden wir
reduzieren wir werden auch die
unterbringung in den kasernen so tun wir
haben das unter der überschrift
auflockerung fixiert also das heißt es
gibt keine vier mann unterbringung mehr
sondern es gibt eine aufgelockerte
unterbringung so dass also die
möglichkeit der späteren ansteckung auch
reduziert wird wir brauchen aber
natürlich die soldaten und zur
personelle einsatzbereitschaft auch
künftig weiter fortzusetzen
weitere themen lehrgänge sprachen sie an
man kann's pauschalieren indem man sagt
die laufbahn lehrgänge also die relevanz
haben für die die laufband und für die
dienstposten bezogenheit diese lehrgänge
finden weiter statt allerdings in
gewandelter form teilweise auch unter
nutzung digitaler techniken was wir
komplett ausgesetzt haben sind die
sogenannten weiterbildungsmodule also
alle dinge die jetzt nicht zwingend sinn
um den einsatz auftrag zu erfüllen daher
ergeben sich dann auch unterschiedlichen
blickrichtungen auf bestimmte
ausbildungseinrichtungen also wenn sie
an die führungsakademie haben durch
gucken
dort gibt es im grunde zwei laufbahn
lehrgänge der rest ist weiterbildung
wenn sie nach koblenz schauen zum
zentrum innere führung dort ist im
grunde alles weiterbildung deswegen ist
auch dort der komplette betrieb
eingestellt
also insofern gibt es unterschiedliche
wahrnehmungen quer durch die republik
die ausbildung in den truppenteilen für
die einsätze läuft weiter wie bisher so
dass wir die auch in der zukunft
sicherstellen können jetzt hier im saal
die fragen der beiden kolleginnen rechts
und in der mitte und beginnen
jetzt haben
ich will vielleicht mit dem der letzten
frage beginnen wir das insofern auch
wichtig ist nicht nur oder über den den
die klassische definition kritische
infrastruktur haben wir zur zeit auch
eine debatte darüber was ist
systemrelevant und das ist dort zum
beispiel wichtig weil wir bei der
schließung der kindertagesstätten und
der schulen mit den bundesländern
vereinbart haben dass es ein notbetrieb
gibt die insbesondere eltern in anspruch
nehmen können die in systemen relevanten
bereichen arbeiten und sie haben eben zu
recht darauf hingewiesen logistik also
unsere läger sind mit blick auf
lebensmittel und andere sind gut gefüllt
aber die logistik muss stimmen
krankenhäuser können dann funktionieren
wenn die hygiene wenn die wäschereien
funktionieren also das heißt in zeiten
von corona lernen wir dass
systemrelevant viele bereiche sind dann
die wir zuerst gar nicht denken insofern
muss man das der lage angepasst auch
immer wieder organisieren die frage wie
sich zum beispiel die lieferketten
darstellen ist von bundesland zu
bundesland verschieden
wir haben zum beispiel insbesondere
einen hinweis bekommen aus brandenburg
weil dort viele der logistikunternehmen
eben auch mit
personal arbeiten die einpendler sind
zum beispiel aus polen
wir haben umgekehrt andere bereiche bin
ich ja mein eigenes heimatland denke wo
wir sehr viele einpendler zum beispiel
aus frankreich haben also das sind
insbesondere auch grenzregionen die
betroffen sind
es gibt aber auch von anderen
bundesländern eben auch anfragen wenn
sozusagen die zivilen kapazitäten nicht
reichen würden ob wir einspringen
könnten
wir haben dafür sowohl fahrzeuge als
auch personal zur verfügung wie viel und
was exakt kann der generalinspekteur ihn
auch noch einmal verdeutlichen
vielleicht gleich dazu also wir haben
rund 7500 lkws unterschiedlicher typen
also bis zum 15 tonner können rund
43.000 tonnen gewicht transportieren das
ist so die kapazität die wir haben
wir haben das aufgeteilt in der republik
von nord bis süd also wenn sie wollen
von delmenhorst bis füssen mit insgesamt
zwölf logistik und versorgungs
bataillonen die steuerung unserer
eigenen logistik transport heute schon
läuft über wilhelmshaven über unser
logistikzentrum
dort ist seit gestern die komplette
führung bereitschaft hergestellt das
heißt also sobald hier ein ad hoc bedarf
kommt der über amtshilfe dann
entsprechend beantragt wurde sind wir in
der lage hier schnell auszuhelfen sowohl
mit fahrzeugen aber natürlich auch mit
ausgebildeten fahren
gut dann bitte ihre frage und dann macht
herr m
was das thema medizinische güter und
persönliche schutzausstattung anbelangt
sind wir insofern daran beteiligt dass
wir eben über das beschaffungsamt die
verträge ausgehandelt haben auch
abgeschlossen haben dass wir dort wo es
notwendig ist wenn die ware ankommt auch
im eigenen lager des totalen
unterbringen
das geht aber das ist auch so vereinbart
jetzt im grunde genommen das
bundesgesundheitsministerium über und
das bundesgesundheitsministerium wird in
absprache mit den bundesländern und auch
einen nachbarn dort festgelegten
bedarfen und schlüssel dann eben auch
weiter verteilen und insbesondere soweit
das möglich ist eben auch verteilen
unter nutzung der zivilen
logistikbranche denn wir sehen ja dass
viele wirtschaftsbetriebe auch unter
druck sind und deswegen wollen wir die
kapazitäten auch nutzen was berlin
anbelangt gibt es in der tat planungen
ein
spezielles in einem messegelände ein
spezielles krankenhaus mit 1000 betten
zu richten
dazu ist bei der bundeswehr angefragt
worden ob wir mithelfen können sozusagen
beim aufbau eines solchen krankenhauses
das wird zurzeit gerade auch in
absprache durch geprüft es liegt
allerdings das war zumindestens mein
kenntnisstand heute morgen noch kein
offizielles hilfeersuchen von der
berliner seite vor
und ich will an der stelle auch ganz
deutlich sagen wir können möglicherweise
beim aufbau helfen wir können auch
möglicherweise helfen was dann
feldbetten oder anderes anbelangt aber
wir können ein solches krankenhaus eben
nicht mit eigenem personal betreiben
denn das wäre dann personal das wir
wiederum etwa aus dem
bundeswehrkrankenhaus berlin abziehen
müssten nun das steht sozusagen in der
normalen struktur geben ja auch in der
planung aber das ist im moment der stand
der dinge
[Musik]
30 nicht ein paar minuten hatten wir
sehen das heißt die idee zu sagen dass
ihnen die frage kann ich grenzen wird
auch von frank jordans von epi gestellt
nach der testung von bundeswehrsoldaten
also konkret werden die regelmäßig
getestet auch wenn sie nur milde oder
gar keine symptome haben also was das
irak mandat anbelangt wir haben das
sozusagen auch noch einmal angemeldet
haben als bundesregierung dem bundestag
und auch den regierungsfraktionen die
vorhaben gemeldet die in der nächsten
woche auch möglicherweise bei einer
verkürzten sitzungswoche dringend
besprochen werden müssen sie wissen wir
müssen das eine oder andere
infektionsschutzgesetz und anderer
gesetze jetzt auch schnell auf den weg
bringen damit wir ein anderer stelle
handlungsfähig sind und wir haben als
bmvg auch das irak mandat mit dazu
angemeldet weil der anteil luftbetankung
der
und auch die möglichkeit dass wir die
ausbildungs anteile in der nato mandat
überführen
der bedarf der des neu angepassten
mandates und wenn das nicht bis ende
märz der fall ist dann müssten wir zum
beispiel mit der luftbetankung auch
entsprechend aussetzen bis das man da
dann die hürde im deutschen bundestag
genommen hat ich schaue gerade zum ge
was die aktuellen zahlen der
krankmeldungen angelangt muss man gucken
die zahlen sind da kann der ge auch noch
mal sagen weil die verändern sich im
moment auch fast stündlich das können
sie sich vorstellen und das gleiche gilt
auch für die frage wie wir mit den test
für unsere eigenen soldaten verfahren ja
die zahlen die ich habe die sind
natürlich jetzt von heute vormittag also
begründete verdachtsfälle insgesamt in
der bundeswehr 397 bestätigte fälle 52
keine todesfälle die weiter in
behandlung sind zurzeit noch insgesamt
49 soldaten in der häuslichen quarantäne
zu hause und zwei noch im zentralen die
übrigen sind schon gesund entlassen
in den auslandseinsätzen haben wir
keinen einzigen fall aktuell der mit
corona virus infiziert ist machen wir
eine testung wir machen keine reihen
testung das heißt also nur derjenige der
sich mit symptomen beim arzt meldet wird
dann befragt also er meldet sich der
regel auch telefonisch wie das auch
draußen der fall ist und wenn es dann
entsprechende kriterien gibt die auch so
sind wie sie 1000 sind die eine testung
erforderlich machen dann tun wir dies
das heißt also da es unwahrscheinlich es
nicht wesentlich von von dem vorgehen im
bereich außerhalb der bundeswehr
wir haben wenn ich das ergänzen darf
auch bisher sehr konsequent sozial bei
jedem verdachtsfall der aufgetreten ist
dann auch wirklich
sehr großflächig alles was in kontakt
war unter quarantäne gestellt wir haben
die für zum beispiel geschlossen als
dort im fall aufgetreten ist und
versuchen damit natürlich auch
entsprechend einzudämmen und versuchen
mit den test kapazitäten die vorhanden
sind auch so umzugehen dass wir die
tests wirkt sich auch für diejenigen
dann auf jeden fall haben die symptome
zeigen und die auf jeden fall auch
getestet werden müssen
wir haben im beschaffungsamt das ja auch
was die weiteren rüstungsprojekte
anbelangt eine große rolle spielt
zurzeit in der priorisierung zwei ganz
klare schwerpunkte das eine ist eben
alles was im zuge von bekämpfung von
corona geschafft werden muss das zweite
ist die initiative verbesserung der
einsatzbereitschaft da haben wir ja
maßnahmen identifiziert die auch zu
einer schnelleren einen schnelleren
zulauf von material und so weiter
beitragen sollen aber was wir im moment
natürlich feststellen ist dass in der
frage auch der entsprechenden industrie
in den industriellen kapazitäten also
dort wo es um die instandhaltung geht wo
es und die werften geht oder anderes das
dort natürlich zunehmend auch
kapazitäten wegbrechen weil entweder
arbeitnehmerinnen oder arbeitnehmer
erkrankt sind
weil
material eben nicht vorhanden ist weil
auch die abhängig sind von von
entsprechenden lieferketten und das kann
das ist im moment noch nicht gravierend
aber das kann natürlich im laufe des
jahres zu einschränkungen auch der
geplanten ausrüstung verbesserung der
ausrüstung führen
das kann dazu führen dass möglicherweise
etwa liegezeiten bei werften auch noch
mal länger sind als das geplant war
da sind wir natürlich genauso von der
industrie abhängig wie andere kunden in
deutschland auch so im saal habe ich
jetzt keine fragen
doch hering hat noch eine frage im saal
dann habe ich noch zwei fragen von außen
notiert
[Musik]
jetzt haben sie das geld ist wie sie
zeichnet der abstimmung mit anderen
anlegen der nato der strafe nämlich die
schreiberin der
also cyber angriffe sind für uns wie
gesagt mittlerweile ja eine realität
auch da würde ich noch mal um ergänzung
bieten wie die zahlen sich zurzeit
verhalten
wir sind natürlich in den militärischen
bündnissen zum beispiel im rahmen der
nato auch ein austausch über die
situation in den einzelnen staaten
ich habe gerade gestern mit meiner
französischen kollegin telefoniert und
wir haben verabredet dass noch in dieser
woche eine schaltkonferenz oder eine
video konferenz stattfinden soll alle
europäischen kolleginnen und kollegen
aus dem verteidigungsbereich wo es darum
geht dass wir mit blick auf die aufgaben
und das ist das thema das ich im grunde
neben ja genannt habe die struktur also
eigenschutz aber auch hilfestellung in
der eigenen bevölkerung und die frage
wie geht es in den einsetzenden einsatz
gleichen verpflichtungen weiter dass wir
uns darüber austauschen
aber klar ist natürlich auch dass jede
armee zur zeit vor allen dingen im
eigenen land auch gebraucht wird auch
eine entsprechende rolle spielt und
darauf natürlich auch moment
konzentriert ist dann abschließend ich
habe heute keine aktuellen zahlen zu
selber mit denn da solche matches kann
ich ihnen gerne nachliefern das ist kein
problem
gut dann abschließend versuche ich mal
die fragen die wenn ich das richtig sehe
jetzt hier vieles überschneidet sich ja
von außen noch offen geblieben sind zwei
fragen ranken sich um das thema
beschaffung von benno könig vom afw und
angelika mistelbach vom ärzte
nachrichtendienst zum einen beobachten
sie bei den beschaffungsvorgängen einen
internationalen verdrängungswettbewerb
und dann die frage ob sie etwas dazu
sagen können
wie material das auf diesem weg
beschafft wird unter umständen auch dann
am ende bei niedergelassenen ärzten
landen kann und dann die nachfrage von
daniela fietz vom rnd noch mal ob sie
bei amtshilfe anfänger wie sie bei
amtshilfe anfragen feststellen ob
tatsächlich keine zivile struktur die
erfragten leistungen erbringen kann
wie gehen wir mit der letzten frage bei
der amtshilfe
das ist natürlich etwas was insbesondere
in der jeweiligen situation und damit
auch über unsere landeskommandos vor ort
mit gutachten und entschieden wird
es geht immer um die frage was ist
notwendig was haben wir in der ressource
und etwa insbesondere bei der frage
amtshilfe die eben auch das thema
unterstützung etwa
von polizeien oder ähnlichem anbelangt
da gibt es sehr genaue rechtliche
vorgaben und deswegen sind das auch
immer fragen die dann im
verteidigungsministerium selbst noch mal
geprüft und entschieden werden
der zweite punkt beschaffung
es ist so dass die die rückmeldung die
wir haben natürlich ist dass wir im
moment feststellen dass auf diejenigen
die medizinische produkte und die
schutzausrüstungen herstellen es
natürlich einen großen run gibt und wenn
man sieht dass viele dieser produktion
eben mittlerweile nicht mehr in
deutschland nicht mehr in europa sondern
zum beispiel in china sind und dass
gerade eine produktion war die in den
letzten wochen eben auch unter verfahren
worden ist dann macht das deutlich dass
eben die produktion daraus knapp ist
mittlerweile stellen wir fest dass china
die produktion ja auch noch mal
angefahren hat und insofern der markt
oder dort auch kapazitäten durchaus
wieder zur verfügung stehen
und ich halte das auch für eine
selbstverständlichkeit nach dem bier
auch aus europa heraus ja in den
anfangszeiten von corona china mit
material auf geholfen haben dass das
jetzt sozusagen auch im umgekehrten weg
funktioniert was ich auch feststellen
kann ist dass es immer mehr auch
deutsche unternehmen gibt die ihre
kapazitäten hochfahren oder sagen sie
produzieren eigentlich etwas anderes
aber sie sind in der lage sehr schnell
auch anzupassen und engpässe auszufüllen
also es gibt ein hohes maß an
hilfsbereitschaft an kreativität und das
ist zuerst einmal ein sehr sehr gutes
zeichen
und dass wir in der lage sind auch über
unsere eigenen
dafür hinaus auch zu helfen auch in
europa das hat man ja gerade gestern
nach gesehen als eine masche an
medizinischem gerät an und
schutzausstattung zum beispiel nach
italien gegangen ist dann auch unter
zuhilfenahme der bundeswehr bei wir die
logistik da organisiert haben und das
ist ein ganz wichtiges signal
insbesondere auch an die europäischen
länder die es zur zeit noch wesentlich
schlimmer trifft als das für uns der
fall ist deutlich zu machen
auch in zeiten von europa gilt
europäische solidarität
wir stehen zum beispiel auch über
unseren sanitätsbereich im kontakt mit
den italienischen kollegen
also insofern versuchen wir auch da im
rahmen des möglichen zu helfen
immer unter wahrung dessen was unsere
eigene bevölkerung natürlich braucht ja
frau ministerin gerade zorn heels vielen
dank für den sony teams nochmal
ergänzung
denn es ist tatsächlich steigend danke
auch für den nachtrag danke noch mal
eben alles alles gute
bleiben sie gesund